Now it's time to dive in and
start exploring how to
create our own watch faces.
The best way to start is to look at
some of the existing samples and
see how they work.
So go to File, Import Sample,
and type in Watchface.
You can create this with
all the default values.
If you expand the Wearable Project,
you'll see there are many
services defined here.
The sample actually includes
more than one watch face.
And we'll see how their defined
shortly and what they do.
So now, you should build and install
the application side to the phone.
Include the green play button.
And then also, build and
install the wearable side as well.
Note that you won't be able
to select a default activity
because neither of these contain one.
So let's run this and
see what it looks like now on the watch.
On the watch we can select
a watch face by pressing and
holding on the current watch face.
You'll then see a selector appear.
If you scroll to the right,
you'll see sample analog.
Select that.
You'll see it shows the time with
hands and to ticking seconds.
Now let's select sample sweep.
This one is very similar
to the sample analog
except you'll notice the second
hand has a smooth sweeping motion.
This refreshes much faster than once per
second to achieve this smooth motion.
Now let's select sample card balance.
This one's not meant to be used as a
watch face, but it's meant to be used to
help you visualize
the dimensions of the beat card.
Now let's select sample tilt.
This is implemented using Open GL and
shows how you can apply arbitrary
3D rotations to a watch face.
Now let's select sample calendar.
This is interesting because it actually
looks at the calendar on your phone and
determines how many meetings
you have coming up and
presents this in a watch face.
So this is an example of how you
can implement awareness about your
users schedule as part of a watch face.
Let's go to sample digital.
You'll notice this one has
a little gear icon underneath.
This allows you to actually configure
the watch face locally from an activity.
So let's select a red background.
Now, interestingly,
we can also go to the phone and
start up the Android Wear companion app.
You'll see that Sample Digital
is selected here, too,
and there's also a little gear icon.
You can click on that and
there are more configuration
options available for the watch.
You'll see how the red background that
we selected earlier is shown here.
This sample actually uses the data API
to synchronize the selections between
the phone and the wearable.
So you can make changes on either side
like adjusting the text color here or
the background here.